this is what you need to go over there
and pretend like you just don't care
leave it has no chance with our up still
right here Chris are you trying to
communicate with me telepathically
that's my seventh birthday whoa see that
listen what I just saw something weird
you guys you gotta feed it right there
look in the mirror dude I can't be
that's definitely me when you figure out
what I'm doing on this tape here that
it's in my dad's old workshops i can
clicking or something hell is that here
we go project Almanac temporal
relocation prototype what does that mean
means time travel we should try to build
it you guys are crazy we can't build a
time machine you see the tape I mean I
think we already did build it all right
you guys ready fist
you're broke you're getting bullied so
let's take this in on for spin we're
trying to communicate with me
telepathically how did you know so we
can go to jail for cheating on the
lottery you guys only have five out of
six numbers to go back into it again I
am NOT winning the lottery what it's
still over a million dollars guys hey
welcome to Maserati can I help you you
see I was either gonna buy one of these
or 17 Toyota Corollas I'm being bullied
in high school Oh Eddie I want to stand
up for myself Huberty I'm everywhere
[ __ ] I love time trouble before the
world ends I have to fall hug
that's be sleeping
what what
like what are you seeing this whatever
we did had some crazy ripple effects
there was a plane crash riots disasters
none of this happened before things are
spiraling out of control you didn't care
that all of your friends could be hurt
Jessie's missing and no
long battle weekend you could kill you
stop